absolutely
[Music]
I'm joined by a man who's probably one
of the most requested guests so far he
is the hurricane and all black Legend
who possessed one of the deadliest fins
in the game while playing over 55 tests
for the All Blacks including the 2011
Rugby World Cup victory he also played
123 games for the Hurricanes where he
played a massive part in their 2016
Championship as well post playing he
moved into coaching where is now widely
regarded as one of the best D coaches in
the country he's also had a number one
selling book winging it an extremely
popular TV show kickoff and somehow
finds himself time to Father four kids
it is of course the very funny great
looking man himself Corey Jane welcome
mate
hey mate how are you nicest thing you've
ever seen to me there's a long intro
you've ticked a few things off hey like
I was you made up a lot of them
yeah well I was actually looking through
a lot of your journey last night and man
it sort of blew me away with how much
you've actually done and like so many
different haircuts as well it sort of
makes it feel like you've done more as
well yeah just moving through the times
man what was your favorite one
oh I could tell you my least favorite
one was the dreads
um I thought at the time
I was growing my hair real long and I
thought in 2006
um obviously six symbol
um with the long hair and I tried I
thought I'm gonna grab some grids here
so I grew up real real long and in my
wedding photo I straightened it
so the missus hates it but um you know I
ended up doing threads and I dreads
model lasted about eight months and then
I have baths every night so every night
they were getting soaked and all the wax
was all over the pillows and it smelled
like a mulching old dog and
so I cut them off it was a bad time in
my life was it inspired by tana and
Rodney and the likes it was it was
because I saw because obviously back
then when I uh I made the canes um
Rodney Tanner they were all in the team
and they looked big and scary uh with
dreads and I thought [__] you know what
I mean what a way to come into the team
and really explode onto the scene with
massive dreads
and I'll look intimidating as them and I
think he had the opposite effect uh to
be fair
um because I didn't look I just looked
like a joke to be fair I think
what do they reckon about it did they
did they embrace you into the dreadlock
community
no they didn't but they they put me to
like I went to Tana's um the person they
all went to to get their hair done so it
kind of made me feel like I was
I was part of the boys but um yeah I
never really got invited around to hang
out with the dread crew
because I remember
um watching you I think I was a ball boy
for Nelson Bays you were playing for
Hawkes Bay and you had them nice long
blonde it was the straight do at the
time I remember thinking man that blonde
skinny white boy is he's a good player
see I think you got a little bit mixed
up there because I actually tried the
that was 2004a yeah and we lost to
Nelson Bays yeah yeah I mean that's
right
um one of my many NPC finals losses but
um I tried a diet Blonde by myself and
it went Ginger so in your eyes you're
younger and you're probably catching
balls you thought it was wrong but it
was Ginger so there was another horrible
hairstyle that I hit it was the glare
from the Nelson's side that's right and
we lost as well so it made it yeah no
mate you've had a few you've even had
like the um sort of mum cut as well like
the sort of Meg Ryan short spiky blonde
hair I like that one
okay keep people guessing now I thought
I gotta keep it just yeah because
there's so many Grays it's falling out
and
I just got to keep it where it is now
yeah keep the head on constantly
uh was there a reason behind all the
haircuts you just like to change out
your style or what was that if it
planned yeah I get I get bored quickly
it's the same thing with um and I've
always been like it same thing with
facial hair like I just oh yeah I get
bored up the same the same look over and
over so I'm always
you know you grow a half beard and then
you'll get chops and then you'll get a
goatee and then you know what I mean so
it's always
I kind of get bored of looking at the
same person in the mirror and sometimes
I'll look and you know I think he's a
different man but um
Brad Pitt I was like hey what are you
doing there but um yes that's kind of
like uh
I guess you're just being bored of same
hairstyle same locks and obviously my
dress since hasn't changed so I'm not
bored of that but um
yeah just always always seemed to change
things
yeah mate well it seemed to work for you
whatever you're doing for whatever
reason but as always on this podcast I
do like to go back to the start of
everyone's journey and I'm pretty Keen
to hear what a young Corey Jane was like
as a young fella talk me through it
well obviously I I could put them to
rumataka in the sixes when I started
rugby so I was born in 99 which is in
Wellington and then I moved up Hut when
I was
when I was five and my old man put me
into rugby
um
I never played it before but he loved it
and I managed to score a couple tries in
room Attack under sixes and I thought
geez I'm not bad at this and then I just
loved rugby from then on and
um I played first five so the rest of
the backline hated me because I never
passed in the ball but hey I'll scoring
twice no x button
um and then because I loved it so much
that old I was always watching the NPC
and
um the old man was from moral so he was
Hawke's Bay was his team and obviously I
was from Wellington but I just like to
you know throughout the years of wallet
before I got to college
I'd watch the games and it might be
Auckland versus
otago and I'd have the guys you know
written down I'd have the whole
competition and so Auckland was playing
otago today and I'd have to
kick like Carlos Spencer or Tony Brown
if they were kicking the ball off while
goal kicking I was goal kicking like
Adrian Cashmore or you know what I mean
so whatever position they were hit the
kick I'd have to go like them if they
were left footed well then I had to kick
left foot and I was playing by myself on
the Rugby field you know and you turn
around and
um great mind was just it was just
working wonders and then you know like
um
so I just you know in the next day would
be a different team playing a different
team and that's kind of like how I
I learned
um you know to kick the ball and pass
and run around and do all that kind of
stuff because I just had to try and
mimic different people and
I guess that's why when I look at rugby
growing up myself I didn't really
mimic one person is just try to take a
little bit out of out of everyone that I
thought was
or that I could do something like that
like Jonah was my favorite player but
clearly
I wasn't going to bump anyone off was I
now so
um I didn't take any from his game but
yeah just growing up uh rugby was that's
what I did
um again from the Mean Streets of Upper
Hutt so
you just roam the streets until the
street lights came on and then
if you weren't home
um the old man would come find you at
your mate's house and
on the door and say get on before you if
I do and
you'd rush off but um
but yeah that was the that was my
younger days
mate did you were you much of a
troublemaker I could imagine you getting
it yourself into a fair bit of trouble
on those streets uh look we used to go
lemon Throne
um when we're little and
there was where I lived uh you got
across the road and then it was like an
Alleyway and on that so I would grab
lemons from the tree at the beginning of
the alleyway and would go to the back
and the fence would angle down a little
bit and so when the cars would come down
we'll lock and then we'll just time it
and throw the lemons and try to you know
hit the cars obviously we weren't trying
to make them crash but let's go clever
We Were Young you don't think that far
ahead as soon as you hear the bang on
the car and the car stops you gas it
back through the alleyway and my house
was across the road so you're always
safe
um
so you know that kind of stuff but speed
training well that's what I mean you
know and Agility to climb over fence and
you know get into safety really really
fast
so when you're playing those games in
the the backyard did you say you're by
yourself like replicating the passing
and stuff yeah so I'd go down to
the Rugby field like so where I was
uh you know 500 meters away there was a
school and so it was only a Littlefield
because there's only intermediate so the
field wasn't a proper
Rugby field that we play on so it was
smaller so I'll just go and you know
you'd pretend to pass a little bit and
then you'd catch it and I'd kick to the
corner and then you'd have a line out
that you're pretended or they want it so
it's all turnover so that if they kick
it and there's a try on the corner I'll
score a hissing try and then you gotta
set up the goal kick and
so then I'd you know get home and I'll
be like oh well that game Wellington won
against Hawke's Bay and it was 32 you
know and then you go round two who was
playing and
um so yeah I used to do that
and then I used to because we we didn't
I used to get a ball every now and then
but I used to kick it on our house
on our lawn and it was a chimney and
then the bedroom was like for lounge and
in my mom's bedroom so it looked like a
post and there was a window underneath
it
and so I used to kick the ball over and
sometimes I'll hit the window and smash
it and you can hear the old man going ah
[__] in the lounge excuse my language
but he knew I was out there getting
better so he kind of and he was a
builder so he could fix it so do you
you've got no brothers or sisters you've
got no siblings I've got an older sister
yeah I got an older sister that um she's
two years older didn't want to Bow those
imaginary games no she didn't want to
bother that
um she played netball and
um yeah then she decided instead of
playing sports she would have a kid at
16 and 17 so
she went a different direction
wait I love I love how you've just
played games by yourself oh that's so
good just got better
passing to yourself I'm playing for both
teams as well man my my kids need to
take a lesson out of that but they
always want someone to play but you can
actually do it by yourself but you can
do a lot of things by yourself mate my
concern on technology all the time so I
don't even care
but you obviously loved it and um when
did you sort of know you're good was
that straight away from their first
touch first couple of tries you knew it
no I thought I was good at uh until I
went to college you know because I I'd
make little rip teams and you know you
score I scored a lot of tries or
whatever and I played well in my my
junior
ages and then I kind of got to I was
little you know you know the feeling
mate yeah
um
and then I got to like college and
I I made I didn't make the first 15 till
I was sixth one but I could have made it
at 50 uh fifth form but
the the guy that I was going to take his
position it was his last year and they
said oh it's his last year
you know we'll keep them near that kind
of wrong
um and so I missed out on Wellington
under 16s
you know two years uh didn't get a
secondary school trial
um
you know I still thought I was good
enough and so I'd walk around school and
my goal was to be in all black so even
if I missed out on teams it kind of
drove me to get better where
you know some people were like oh missed
out I'll just give up where
made all that running around by myself
yeah I want to get better was my dream
was to be in all black so
um kind of drove me to
uh you know keep pushing harder and try
to get better and so I didn't make any
teams at school
um we won our division two
um final against Manor College I'm at T
Allison was the other first five and I
was I was first five and we beat them
um
but he was he was a big dog at
um at school he was he was above way
above me was he was he still catching
the high balls on his goatee he was
going off his left footstep that he just
stood with everyone and
um run to the line and got no right
footsteps so he just keeps going off his
left
um that's what he did back in the day
yeah and I read something that um I
think was when you're young and I think
your granddad had died and
um you left a note in his coffin saying
um like sorry like now you're not gonna
see me become an all black or or
something along those lines do you
remember that or like what's the story
behind that one it's pretty powerful
I remember it because
uh when I first made the All Blacks
um
I came home and old lady and
um Dad came up and she actually told me
that that's what I did when because I
was 12 when he died and I I don't
remember it but she told me that I I did
that and
um so it was kind of like a bit more of
her feelings than it was mine because I
kind of remember it but it was pretty
cool if I didn't you mate you knew from
a long way out that you're going to get
there yeah she was she was crying and
all that kind of stuff so that got me
excited but
um
yeah so then how did you get I managed
to make it into I guess it was Hawke's
Bay first but Wellington as well what
was the pathway from school being this
guy who couldn't quite make the 16s
yeah actually
uh got into the Wellington under 19s I
think it was my second year uh out of
school
um
I thought yeah and I was playing Prem
rugby then and so I made the team and I
was put on the wing and I I grew up
playing first five and fullback
and I was put on the wing and then so
half of the season
uh you know we were playing and I had
Jimmy Goff of pity wipoo they were all
in my under 19s and the fullback got
injured and they were trying to decide
who can go to fullback and Jimmy nickel
well he's actually a fullback
so I kind of played full back then and
um
John Plumtree and Chris Borden it were
like they're all ah the All Blacks the
Lions coaches
um and then the following year I made
the Wellington Colts and
kind of like
got caught into the lions uh with them
for the last
three or four games
um so that's kind of that was in 2003 so
that's where I kind of started my NPC
and then the following year I went to
Hawke's Bay because of
um I got put on loan because Shannon
Puckett was
the number 115. true so they're just
willing to send you up there for game
time was that was that the reason they
sent you up there yeah a little bit of
that a little bit of um
I I was working as well so I'd have to
um you know to before the lines and it
got picked I'd be in the academy so I'd
go and train at six in the morning and
then I'd have to go to work and then I'd
have to get back into Wellington again
and try and train so you start at six
A.M
in town training then you don't get home
till eight o'clock at night and
so by time I made it you know I
shattered I go to
um Fitness sessions and I'd be in ripped
up shoes and I just come from work and
don't worry about stretching just get
into that 40 meter sprint in the 50
meter sprint that you just have to do
and so they're kind of like well this
kid's probably not where he needs to be
in
um so they said look you could either
pay for the B team or
go to Hawke's Bay and actually be in an
environment to grow and get better so I
think it was the best thing for me
because it was awesome environment up
there in Hawkes Bay in 2004 and I was 21
and
went out an awesome time no doubt and
were you under the guidance of the great
Karen Kane
at that that season that's correct
that's correct I was you must have a few
good KK stories mate he um be awesome
because he like obviously he was trying
to come off different ways to play a
game and he had a you know a few
scenarios in his head there he thought
rugby can go this way and so I didn't
mind his his ideas one story
um you know he doesn't mind firing up
now and then
um
you would have seen it and we were Corey
Opera
um wasn't he played for my
um Upper Hutt team and he ended up
playing for bad opinion in North Harbor
uh his Center and so I hurt my ankle one
game and we were supposed to play in the
east coast and I didn't pay that week
and then we got called into his office
in I think at that time I was top try
school or equal top try score so I was
we're going all right I was going all
right and then he called us into the
office and set us down and he was like
uh Corey mate you're going awesome to
causea going great you're having a great
year mate keep going keep going like
that you you're playing awful you're
like having to just lit me up right in
front of him and I was just like holy
money goes you need to be better the way
you're playing and I was just like and
then we walked out and he goes I think
he was talking to the wrong Corey but it
was yeah
I was just like holy moly I thought I
was going good but
clearly not
straight between the eyesight always
from him
yeah
so then into the New Zealand seven setup
um how did that one come about where'd
you get picked up from I guess it was
Gordon kitchens at the time yeah so I
was um I was in the it was 2009 leading
up to the 2006 season I was in The Wider
training group for the Hurricanes
um
and over the Christmas period
um Wellington sevens was played and
Scott Waldron was coaching them and he
was oh come play and I was like oh yeah
so kind of asked coops if we can go down
and play because you know why the
Trading Group in it and so I went down
and played the Queenstown oh yeah uh
tournament and
you know I did okay and
got called into the New Zealand Vault it
was the first part of the year so I got
caught into the camp
and made it was the hardest
couple of days of training I've ever
been involved in you know you roll up
and
you do the phosphate
you know the what is it eight or ten
Sprints for 30 as hard as you can 30
seconds rest Sprint again 40 meters and
then 15 minutes later you do a beep test
then you had to get over 13 I think it
was
um during the season where you had to
come back and so oh that blew me out and
then you go and play games and
um I remember coming back like made I
made the team which was cool and
um
I ended up coming back to the water you
know to the canes and on the Monday and
I tried to get out of my car and I I
just I couldn't walk my back was gone my
legs were in bits and it took so long to
get a rugby league park into the
draining training basin I saw coops
Colin Cooper and he was just like I go
I'm no good man I can't I can't even
walk and as I go home and rest up
um but I actually the coolest thing
about that that story is that I spoke
about it before times having a giggle
but I saw him the year before in the
Wellington
um in 2005 he was at the Wellington uh
tournament and crowell's rehearsing the
pumping all kind of stuff and I was just
like ah man I want to be there next year
kind of you know that and yeah cool
story I got to do it the next year so
um it was quite cool yeah what was it
like playing at that um tournament that
was that was one of the best sporting
events on the calendar gutted that that
all sort of fell to piece as that one
yeah they ruined it out because I
remember going you know as a young
18 year old or 17 or whenever we first
started going and
make just awesome party and I don't
think apart from when New Zealand was on
you're just walking around The Concourse
you know yeah hearing a few buildings
and all that kind of stuff so
but they're actually being and you know
be a part of it was
was awesome
um the year that I was in it
I think they might have been about eight
or nine new guys so you know we're just
trying to get our feel at DJ Forbes and
all that they were first years as well
with me yeah that's right we didn't win
a final
um
I think you know we keep losing the
semis or but I was I mean just just
being part of it and looking at the
crowd and just go this is you know
because you know when you go and watch
it and New Zealand go out to play like
the crowd just all comes rolling back in
yeah you know the atmosphere builds up
and all that kind of stuff so actually
being a part of it on the field
and feeling that was was awesome yeah
you said you didn't win much that year
but you you what was it that yeah that
you won the Commonwealth Games
that's correct yep yeah that's correct
so then what was it like going to the
Commonwealth Games well it's cool
because we're in um the village and so I
like never kind of experienced anything
like that and so
you know you got
different like there was the netball and
the swimmers and the basketball and we
had our own little area and then every
other team and obviously weird touch who
was real hard out on what we ate and
you'd go to where the food but is under
the big Marquee and all that and
there's food for days because you know
different countries and what they eat
and
you're watching
some some athletes eat fried chicken and
all that kind of stuff and
you're eating rabbit food because that's
all you're allowed and then but just to
see different you know like just to see
different um
sporting athletes different countries
all walking around on the same kind of
Village was
made it was it was awesome and
um
like we didn't get to experience it too
much at the back end when we won because
we had to go to
uh another tournament so we won I think
we had like two days before we hit the
go where some people went uh the
Commonwealth Games Were what not get the
stay to the end of the
you know really experience it if you're
at the beginning but we weren't able to
do that and Negley was there anyone who
you got super star struck from by just
walking around or seeing
um eating some of that fried chicken or
so no but what Valerie Adams because she
was old so she came around the corner
when we were we were doing I think a
hacker practice or something all right
something she came around I was just
like wow yeah she was a big human and I
was just like wow she's dominating Sport
and work on stuff so I was like who and
I was just like holy moly you know when
you see people in real life and then um
yeah
for Jamaica
he was there and um he walking around
like a
messy mess of human but just you know
commanding Swagger 100 yeah and it was
the fastest guy in
um you know so seeing him was kind of
like well
um
they probably said the same thing when
they saw us you know what I mean well
they probably thought you were Brad Pitt
as most people do you know
who's this Little Pony guy over here
how hard did you find it um
transitioning from sevens to 15s going
both ways well because I wasn't a sevens
player so
um
because everyone
go are you a seventh player that tune
into 15s but I only played
um the five the five tournaments you
know like I played Four
on the world circuit and then the
Commonwealth game so I wasn't really a
big
sevens player to start with so
um coming back out of it and that was
always little so it's not like I had to
put on weight or drop weight to
um
so I didn't find it that hardly I know
some people
struggle a little bit with the you know
obviously got to drop weight or pick up
weight toward the Collision areas
um but I never went into collisions
anyway so
did you feel like it helped your game
did it did you did you feel like you
came back when you went to the
hurricanes and the lines when you came
back did you feel a better player
potentially Fitness or skill sets like
anything like that I just I confidence I
think yeah you know when you're on a
sevens and you're on the field and it's
there's a massive part you know open
area and
confidence to back yourself to beat
somebody but also
confidence defensively because if you
don't work hard and make a tackle
you know they're scoring a try so kind
of
having that little bit of confidence to
go actually I can go and do this and
I think I bought that out of
my sevens to come into the 15th and I
still had a little bit of confidence but
you know what I mean once you've got
that much room and
it's a bit more Cutthroat that if you
make a mistake
you're probably going to be seen
um
yeah
it always seemed to be a really
confident player
um was it how you're always feeling like
throughout the whole sort of process
always felt like you're good enough
always
felt like you were you had the talent
and confident in your own ability well I
just
yeah I was confident but I just dreamed
on this that was my dream and so I
wanted to
I wanted to make it and
so I guess just going out there and
backing myself and I knew I knew my game
I knew what I couldn't do
and I knew you know what my strengths
were and I was never the
you know I was quick but I wasn't the
fastest guy I wasn't an Elton else but
you know speaks to that running around
the field so I knew my ability growing
up was how do I beat somebody and you
know with quickness or footwork with a
fend you know how do I chip and Chase or
whatever it was how can I use my skill
set
to benefit me so I can go out into the
field and be really really confident and
I kind of learned that
um
you know that kind of growing up that
I knew what what I was good at and what
I wasn't and it helped me what age did
you sort of realize that that's like
pretty good self-awareness to realize
what you're good at play to your
strengths
um a lot of guys I feel like struggle
with that especially coming through as a
as a young young kids but what I should
do sort of comprehend all that but I
know I was old as well like I didn't
make
I was just turned 23 when I made seven
so I was an old person so I kind of in
my head probably at 2021 thought that I
was good
and
uh should have been picked but I
probably wasn't you know I probably
didn't have that understanding for
um
you know everything else I knew I was a
little bit of talent but I guess the
work ethic and working harder and trying
to improve my game probably wasn't near
and you see guys like that now and it
wasn't until I was about 23 I made the
sevens and then 24 hurricanes and 25 I
made so I was an old all black
um I wasn't making towards 25 but so I
knew then exactly
what I knew my game was in
um did I just had to say well how long
am I going to stay in and live this
dream for and it was I guess the
challenge after that and what was it
like um getting that all black call
always a pretty special moment for
everyone no doubt you had a good one
yeah it was um it topped off a horrible
night so we um
this is in 2008 we so 2000 uh 2006 I was
at one in ten we lost the NPC final to
waikato
2008 R7 we lost to Auckland and then in
2008 we were playing Canterbury in the
final and we lost that as well eight
seven I think it was or seven six or
something like that and so we went into
the changing rooms and
you know everyone's down because he just
lost another final and I heard
uh our team manager walk up to Jamie
Joseph Jamie Joe was um the coach then
and he said yep the same guys and Jose
Ross CJ and I was just like
I wonder what he's talking about so then
when we sat down and we had a yarn and
because they wanted the boys to do media
the next day they were in Wellington
they go oh and the All Blacks are you
guys are going to get told tonight but
it's not announced till tomorrow uh the
same guys and he said you know and all
that and then he said Jose
Ross and I was like so I started getting
real nervous because I heard those names
just before and that order knows and he
goes in Cory and also thought oh like
um that was kind of let's go
we lost the final but that kind of went
out the window and was just like oh my
god
um
so that was like a kind of topped off a
bad night like I said before
um and that's how I found out were you
expecting it at all or how how much out
of the blue was it for you uh
and I was hoping because I played well
um yeah those couple of years uh 2007 I
I was my first Cairns year and I made
the junior all blacks and I played fuzzy
it was the coach back then and I played
four out of the five games uh in in that
campaign and
and then I did all right
um for Super Rugby and that so I was
kind of like I must be in the and then
NPC so I was like I must be in the frame
somewhere but I'd never been picked
before so you never quite know
um
if you're in there and then so I made it
and next morning I had to do media
um in Wellington with Jose gear and
first time I ever got the mick t-bomb um
Ted and
um yeah in the morning and
I was kind of
kind of surreal kind of thing there the
now you made the All Blacks you made the
you know head coach
for the first time so that kind of made
it topped it off what was he like what
was he like with you
he's interesting he was like um
maybe he's just like how did you sleep
and
I was like yeah it didn't get too much
sleep and
um
he's like there's normally other ways
you can try to get to sleep and I said
yeah I tried to do that but she wouldn't
let me and he's like oh you don't need
to tell me at all but that was what he
was
so that was kind of like the finished
conversation I had with Ted was
made the All Blacks and then he's
trying to talk about getting to sleep
one way or another and um
it's quite cool right you're Graham
Henry's impersonations a lot better than
your KK's
oh yeah right I wanted to throw in a lot
of swear words if it was going to be um
KK
because you were um like you said a
little bit of an older all black 25 is
relatively old especially for a Winger
um day Boom for the All Blacks did you
feel
um less intimidated going into the
environment you obviously would have
felt like the guys
um you would have played against most of
them all with a lot of them felt like
they respected you and you sort of
earned that Jersey
well I like to think that I own the
juicy but
um
yeah I kind of I I get Starstruck when I
see people like I
um you know growing up watching you know
people on TV and that you see them and I
still do it now I'm like yeah you know
how people that you notice on TV and
they always seem to stand out in the
crowd
and I do the same thing
um
so to me you know like coming into the
environment and
you know you're watching the DC's and
the Richie
um Richie's on TV and all that kind of
stuff and it's just like far out
um
but I was also like actually I'm
I've made it quite late and they're only
a couple years older than me so I can't
be too bloody intimidated from them
because
it's not like I'm a 20 year old that's
just rolled into the team I'm actually
you know supposed to be mature
um
so it's kind of like with a near and
try to put your best foot forward and
um get comfortable I think the coolest
thing was
you know you're in the team but I my
first test match was in Hong Kong
probably stealing your questions but my
first test match was in Hong Kong and
um you know after the game it's kind of
like I remember DC and all that going
welcome to the club you know what I mean
and so now you're officially
um and all black so that was
that was an awesome feeling what was
that game like was that the one with
beaver's Infamous kicked attached no
that was that wasn't 2010 so 2008. okay
we paid them twice uh 2008
I um we got into the ground and nervous
and I shot out onto the field to warm up
and I was only one out there for ages
trying to warm up and I was only on the
bench and I'm trying to warm up for a
bit running you know doing the a script
and all that kind of stuff and then I'm
like I need to go for a mummy here so I
needed to go toilet so I ran back in and
I was like where's everyone and then
everyone was just coming up now because
I'd gone I'd shut the bed and gone way
too early
um because obviously my news I just
dropped my gears
some straight out and
so I came in to go toilet and then
everyone came out and um
did their proper warm-ups and then I
came back out so um
it was a good listen the warmest player
on the bench ever oh mate I only got six
minutes at the end too so I warmed up
well to you know way too early was that
a good six minutes am I unreal and it
was um
I remember everyone started getting on
and
um oh suddenly like oh my God I'm the
only one on the bench it's going to be
embarrassing like your first first ever
all black game because I kind of made it
to myself that I'd never go to the All
Blacks my first game was going to be the
one that I played on yeah and
yeah so I was just on the bench he was
getting on I said it's my first all
black game I'm not gonna get on this is
going to be embarrassing so you kind of
like start stretching you know how it is
on the on when you're on the bench and
it's starting to try to stretch make the
coaches you know this guy wants to go on
he's shot yeah he's showing he's the
energy and so
finally I like I think uh there's a
toyava he looked at me and goes oh I
should fake some cramp or something so
he ended up coming off and I
I went on and got six minutes of
pure gold was that true story he fake
cramped oh absolutely no yeah well I
don't know I just think he felt sorry
for me he's just like oh he's gonna be
embarrassed if he poor lead does oh I
was older than him at the time he's
probably like that old guy over there
because he was only 20. yeah we got to
get them all so um
like 20 something I don't know so
yeah I don't know if you faked it but
he got me on yeah yeah and then
obviously the big moment for you um
especially for your all black career was
the 2011 Rugby World Cup we always
expected to make that Squad initially no
it wasn't because
um you know in the 2011 season with the
Keynes and it was one of the worst ones
in poly franchise history it was a lot
of things going on a couple players
uh got told that they weren't
uh weren't required to come back the
next year and then so a lot of the guys
pretty ended up just going
um who's he left and the next year and
um so it was kind of like a weird
um
you know feeling in that camp and I got
told the year before
uh India tour we played Wales the last
game and I got told by Smithy and
um Gilly they go man if you because I
paid at about 90 kgs 91 kgs yeah and
they go look if you can come you know 94
kgs 95 kgs like you'll be unstoppable
you know I mean if you can put that size
on so I was just like okay so in the off
season and preseason Annette trying to
put on size and eat heaps and you know
put on the muscle and all that kind of
stuff and I got to about 94.
couldn't run like I was the guy I was
off I had no string couldn't step I just
couldn't I was I couldn't I couldn't use
that I was too heavy for me and I
remember
halfway through the year Smithy and it
coming up and you know do your skin
folds and they're like
you're up four kgs your skin folds are
up 10 like and I was like
what are you doing and I go well you
guys told me at the end of your tour if
I put on four or five cages I'm gonna be
unstoppable and I said I can't even run
and then
um I kind of made the the All Blacks the
trial Nations back then as injury cover
because obviously I had a bad year I was
fat and overweight and I couldn't run
you couldn't use it and
um broke my I did a compound dislocation
of my finger my ring finger on a jersey
against taranaki and I was supposed to
play the game against Fiji which was our
first game and I couldn't hold the ball
and I was like injury cover here and now
I'm not gonna this is my opportunity and
Ted came to me goes don't worry you'll
play South Africa
um next week at the cake tin and so I
dropped my weight back down
um to 91 where I feel comfortable
and I scored two tries in that one and
kind of made the world cup from that
game
uh
and then you got picked in the World Cup
which was
that was a that was the toughest getting
picked in the World Cup because we were
all away in Port Elizabeth and there
were three or four guys that weren't
going to make the team and we all had to
fly back together
um
so it was real Cutthroat kind of year
there was
who were the three missed out that's
that's a tough long flight
um
Jose gear uh Liam missam I think
and I can't remember somebody else but
it was it was it was because we all have
our own rooms and we're over there and
um you were going to get a message to go
and see the coaches and so they were
going to explain to you why you didn't
make it if you didn't get a message then
the team meeting was at such and such
time so the boys are texting each other
you know like have you heard anything
and you hear your phone go you're like
oh no oh nah man stop it I like so it's
the Avon's on sitting on the edge of
their seat kind of like wow this is
um so it was kind of
it was awesome to make the World Cup but
then kind of like you feel for the leads
that were over there
you know you had to travel back with him
and you wished everyone could have made
it and then what was it like going into
that World Cup obviously huge pressure
from the country all on your shoulders
how was it yeah it was um we lost to
uh we lost that game in Port Elizabeth
and then we lost to Aussie in Brisbane
so we lost the tri Nations before the
World Cup started so I was kind of like
uh-oh and you're in New Zealand and they
lost the last World Cup so it's
um we will we need to win this thing and
but the confidence was there and you
know we started off well and won some
games and
um
made it kind of like I've hadn't
experienced that kind of feeling because
you know we're in New Zealand and yep
some of the games get picked up but to
see people just
filling up the streets and every time
the team bus was you know driving down
the road to get to the stadium like just
hundreds and thousands of people just
you know on the sideline on the side of
the roads and
you know New Zealand kind of really
embraced it and it was an awesome
feeling that every time you you know
went to a game you know everyone was
behind you so it was um
that was awesome and did you feel that
pressure on you personally did you feel
it when you were out there playing or
throughout the weeks did you did you
feel the weight no I didn't because I I
don't want a little bit of pressure
pressure makes you have to compete and
go harder you know what I mean it just
makes you do your job and
um like I was always when I played out I
like to think that I had a good rugby IQ
and I knew that if I did what I needed
to and learned what I needed to game
plan wise skill wise during the week
that the game was easy you know and I
hated being nervous so I made sure I
learned all that stuff said in you get
to the game and just go out there and
compete and
you know that becomes fun so it wasn't
until the final
um when we were playing
uh France and
the second half second you know 30
minutes into the second half where they
were on top of us the whole time and we
were under the pump and so in that part
there I was kind of like looking at the
crowd and I was like they're going to
spit on us and kick us out of New
Zealand and I remember turning to I
remember turning to Israel dick who was
full back and I was like yeah one stage
I was like is he what's the call and he
was like
not looking at me like Ozzy and he
looked at me like what's the call he's
like I don't know like panicking I was
just like
um yeah so I was Panic Station so that
was probably the most time that I was
just like oh no
um but then we stopped them and
last 10 minutes we knew we had it sales
that was probably the time that
uh the pressure in the pennant kicking
kicked in yeah nice it looked like you
guys had it all under control but
actually out there you're all you're all
panicking as he's screaming not sure
what's going on mate looking at him oh
they're gonna look
well they almost did a few weeks earlier
too to be fair and it was your good mate
is he he's obviously spoken about his
side of the story all the questions were
basically about this from the Instagram
but that
Infamous night
um where you were
I guess captured in town
um sleeping pills or
what what do you remember from your side
of that night uh well nothing we've been
told the stories now but what I
remembered was
silly so we um
you know because if you're stuck in the
hotel you're not you know for the World
Cup so there's a couple months of it so
at this stage
um you know you're into your second
month and what we did is
there was a few sleeping pills and so
what we had a mess out I think it was 6
30 and we're like we have a couple
sleeping pills and then get a little bit
donkey on the
um massage table and then we'll go up to
the room and crash out and go to bed
because we had a big Training Day the
next day yeah
and so boom remember doing that and then
we were walking up to the room me Izzy
and Zach and we're like [__] we need we
haven't had dinner
and we're like we better go get some
dinner we're like sweet so
um as he drove his car and we drove
around to the restaurant
and then autopilot
um kicked in so uh broke up the next
morning and I was just like again uh I
think Izzy and pity were rumored
together but we had like modai we just
had pulled out mattresses on the floor
and all that kind of stuff and I woke up
in the morning and I felt good
and Lizzy was like oh I don't feel good
G and I was like man you might have
caught a bug or something you know just
thinking
I don't know he's soft anyway but
um so we ended up going to breakfast and
we went to training and you know I I
don't know about him but I felt fine
trained well and I was playing
um they're quarterfinal it was until
after the court of uh after training and
Shandy took us to the room of you know
kept us on my shoulder come here boys
and we walked into the little office bit
and he was like
I don't know as he said about the taxi
but the receptionist
had sent a note to him and said uh these
guys came in and they looked heavily
intoxicated
um and that's kind of like the note was
and we were like hey now we we were in
bed and they're like nah they said you
came in at 1 30 or one o'clock or
whatever and that was the note and we're
like oh my god what have we done
um yes I don't remember anything didn't
even know and then it wasn't until
you know the next couple of days where
um people from the media were trying to
ring up and say yeah we went to a bar
and
we were behind the bar pouring drinks
for people and
um
apparently I was walking around with one
jandal
um
yeah yeah you've lost the agenda and I
was like no I found one apparently this
is what people were saying so I don't
I don't remember anything and it's just
like
I remember our media guy goes look
we don't don't know what's going to say
it happened people are just writing and
saying that they saw you or writing in
Anything could happen and
so the next couple of nights like I
didn't sleep but the night before the
quarterfinal I I waited till 6 a.m in
the morning to see what was going to
come out in
uh you know on the internet
um yeah so I had no sleep the night
before the quarterfinal I was just like
shattered read it and it's kind of like
Corey Jane boozing
and uh and then there's a little bit
underneath I had a picture of me and
then it was a little bit under here it
said about Israel and I was like hey he
was walking too but obviously I took the
fun for it and he wasn't playing and um
yeah Wayne Smith like apparently he
wanted us gone
um on game day we went to breakfast and
he wasn't there at the time but we had
heard that he had he'd he didn't had
seen it on two days prior when we found
out yeah but Smithy hadn't seen it until
game day until it was out on the front
page you know like a picture of me I
think it was and he was like nah I want
them gone
but you couldn't get rid of them you
know because you you know you can't come
back in if you get rid of themselves
um
but it was a tough it was a tough few
days and it was stupid of us you know
but Izzy I remember him telling me he's
like please man and I was like what and
he's like you've got to carve up you got
to do it for us man because he couldn't
play so I was just like oh no so I
remember
I remember hit um he used to have these
like little energy bullet drinks um back
in the days yeah you would have had them
before yeah and
um you normally have one of them well I
didn't want to stop running I was like
I've got to make up for this so I had
three of them
straight out there to warm up and I was
flying around so in that game I was just
odd on fire trying to run around and
um I remember coming to the dock
afterwards oh after the game and I was
like oh
do you reckon I can get a sleeper to go
to bed and she was like no way not after
three days ago and I was like I had
three of those energy bullets and she
was like what would you do that and I
was like well there was no way I was
going to let myself or the country down
was I so I
um
yeah right it's so crazy but I ended up
here Linda if you want to watch
it was embarrassing because it was um it
was milsy's 100th yeah and we took
yeah not not on purpose but you we took
that that Limelight away from them so
when it was supposed to be about him
and you know get into 100 test matches
is unreal and you got these two idiots
that are in the front page
for something that's completely
different that kind of took the shine
away from them so now we stood up at the
end of it and apologized but you know
apologizing doesn't
make it right you know what I mean so
um
it was a stupid mistake was that the
most nervous you you've ever been going
into a game that well yeah yeah it
didn't help yeah it didn't help and
um
yeah like I you know I tried to make up
for it and
and you know in hindsight like in the
back of the thing it actually did me
wonders because you know for the first
few games
you know everyone was getting an
opportunity to play and
you know so I had the opportunity in
their quarterfinal and it's kind of like
you know I'll never do that again or ask
you know you don't that's stupid to put
that much pressure on you but it kind of
put the pressure on me that I had to go
out there and perform well if I wanted
to be to start in 14 or right wing and
the All Blacks and I knew I had to make
up for so much by stuffing up that it
kind of drove me to actually
you know really get my hit in the game
and
um you know I managed to play all right
in that game and and then again in the
semi-final and not so much in the final
um
but
yeah it was uh it was an interesting few
weeks right you formed the big part of
the bomb squad you you a self acclaimed
nickname I think it was from yourself or
Izzy and Richard Kahu the other Winger
what a what a back three under the high
ball yeah I mean we had like a little
goal for ourselves we just said like if
anything goes up you know we're not in
anything touch the ground you know and
we've got a diffuse bomb bomb after bomb
so that's why we kind of
called ourselves the bomb squad I think
South Africans call their bench it now
so
um
too many years after though boys uh but
yeah like it was kind of like a mindset
for us that we knew that because that's
when back in those days you know like
2009 till then a lot of high balls going
up and
um you kind of
the fullback
pain on the wing kind of you know that's
what kind of happened and we just kind
of made it a
a little goal of ours that it wasn't
gonna they weren't gonna put up bombs
and put us under pressure there and we
weren't going to drop them so you can
count on the backfield and
um kind of gave us that little bit of a
mindset to
to do that right well it definitely
worked and just think about that
sleeping pill like was that something
that you would do quite regularly like
throughout that tournament to cope with
the pressure was it was it a common
practice yeah back then yeah there was a
little bit of it there was a little bit
going around and it was
um and again you're locked into the all
the arrows Inside the Hotel
um you know not you're not doing too
much you're away from your families or
you know most of the time for a long
time and there's that outside pressure
that and I pull it
you know it's probably in the back of
your mind kind of thing I I you know I
and so you end up
taking a sleeper here and going to bed
or taking a couple of sleepers and
sitting there playing PlayStations and
falling asleep and
um just to try to get the time time
passed so there was a little bit going
on and
um
yeah it's
probably not the smartest thing to have
done you know you look back on it and
grow up a little bit and it's like kind
of jeopardized could jeopardize the
World Cup by
you know what I mean um
right yeah I think you know and again a
professional sports there's
again there's a lot of pressure and I
think you know a lot of people have to
try to find their ways to to cope and
um
yeah so it's
not the smartest way to cope though yeah
well especially now that you're coaching
you're probably
I don't know if you'd notice players who
have done it or not but um how you drain
them in
you're surprised what you see
uh well as a player and a coach you know
what I mean it's like I think the
coolest thing about is uh you know and
you'd be the same you know you played
and so you know come on boys made of
yeah
you know what I mean yeah
um
you know it's as as a end of the day you
know you don't want to do anything
stupid as well but
um you don't want them to jeopardize
their career or their health and
you know you just got to try to say look
boys uh end of the day you've got to be
smart here you know what I mean um
because it can go like that yeah and
obviously the success of 2011
um massive wave and then 2015 to the
next World Cup the absolute heartbreak
of I guess missing out on that and World
Cup you spoke about
um the boys who missed down the 2011 one
having to fly back with you but what was
it like being on the other side of it
yeah I knew I wasn't going to make it I
um
but I was I did my ACL
beginning of 2013 I did my MCL ACO and
LCL like the all three or one thing Ben
may actually
um in a touch drill
um tried to kill me I remember that I
actually I remember that yeah and I
tried to do like it was brutal it was
like a rock drill and TJ popped out as a
nine and I try to get a little hit ball
off him and yeah I was in Gisborne or
otaki I think it was we were up there on
a summary yeah that's right and he can
finally align him boom smoked me and I
went straight over my knee
um so they're kind of
hurt my
you know that ruined me for that year
and the knee itself was fine but I keep
having hamstring problems I keep I
hadn't been able to build up the Hemi so
I keep pulling my hemis
through 2014 through 2015.
and when I feel like I'll come right the
Hemi will go again and my last test
match was 2014 and America boom done my
Hemi and I was just starting to feel
fast and good again and then the whole
2015 season I keep
pulling my Hemi
um I did it
the last three weeks of the season and
then I tried to cheat my way and come
back and I did it against the chief so I
ended up missing the final and
everything that's right
um so I knew
I knew the body was starting to break
break down it was
a 32 something then and
so I was in the All Blacks Squad but I
played for the barbarians against New
Zealand maoris and tried to Jackal the
ball and got cleaned out and did a high
ankle sprain
um so I was just like oh it just keeps
getting worse here and then so I'd take
heaps of pots I try and train with the
All Blacks and make it look like I was
fine and then
you know as soon as training is over get
in your room is like an Agony and then
uh so I kind of knew
I kind of knew I was and scuds may he um
you know he came on there he was Unreal
so I was just like well he's clearly
taking my spot yeah
um and the whole of wasaki he did the
same thing he was Unreal too so
um and I knew I was the body was
breaking down so windshield rung
um
I kind of I knew
I knew the bullet was coming so kind of
didn't yeah didn't feel as bad because
um yeah I wasn't in the prime I felt for
Izzy
yeah yeah I feel for Izzy because he was
the same one and he was he's he's five
years younger than me so you know he he
was he was still young and still got a
career we always kind of you know at the
back end yeah and I guess he knew a
little bit earlier with these injuries
and I guess how hard was those injuries
for you to handle mentally like
especially the big knee and then all
these constant hammers just niggly
setbacks after setbacks yeah I never
really because I had surgery until
I think I was 30 when I did my knee and
so I you know got through a few games
and yeah
um just the Hemi just
um you know having the you have to stay
on every day and
I probably you know in my mind I was
like six months for the knee and I can
come back and play sweet that's when the
surgeon said that's what that's when I'm
coming back and I ended up paying the
test matches in it for against France
and at the end of year two and I was no
way really but you're not going to say
no and yeah just just keep doing the
hear me it was it was frustrating
because it just felt like you started
getting back and then boom another three
weeks or bum another four weeks and
um mate it was
it was a frustrating time and so when I
missed out on the All Blacks it was kind
of I knew it was happening
um but then it gave me time to get
healthy through that that NPC at the end
of 15 and then have a mindset going into
the next year because I still had two
more years with the canes to go look
I've got to get this Henry right and
let's see if we can we can still compete
right and did you what
what a 2016 season from I still remember
that try what's that Super Rugby final
try regularly
um what what a game you had that night
yeah it was um I mean that was a cool
Year too because I knew that the hammy
keep going so I had a mindset like I I
don't think I've worked so hard in a
pre-season
as I did that yeah I'll study three or
just tuning 33. and so I worked so hard
on my Hemi net I had a mindset to win
the championship but I also had a
mindset that at 33 years old to show
these young guys that I could still play
and
um you know so and well like I was lucky
that and it's unfortunate that scuds got
injured because he was starting I was on
bench or not and he happened to get
injured at the beginning of the year and
so then I you know I ended up starting
um
yeah I think I started every game except
for one that year and it was unfortunate
for him that he had their the bad injury
but again it was a chance for me to go
out there and compete to that at that
age and we kind of shaped our defense a
little bit different
um
yeah we went in a different direction
and decided that we'll go and get some
teams as you well know and everyone just
kind of embraced it and we actually
started playing some great attacking
rugby but also backed themselves on the
D side and um
and we ended up winning our first
championship was cool yeah did you feel
like your game
um sort of moved from being there
um out and out attacker with the fan the
footwork to more of a defensive
um defensively minded Winger where you
were just shutting off your Edge you're
getting in the ball line getting
intercepts um you're creating a lot more
from your D than potentially your attack
later on yeah I did because and again my
both my knees I'd bed patellas and both
Achilles you know my tendons were
tendonitis was just hell in it your body
wasn't good Nick oh mate I was falling
apart I was in agony so I kind of like I
could hardly ever stepped you know I
could never I couldn't bump people off
at that age so I was just like
mate how do I try to reinvent myself and
stay in this game for another couple
years because you know I don't want to
give up yet the mind's telling me that I
can still keep competing in it yeah even
though the body's saying geared nah so I
kind of had to reinvent myself and I was
just like well if I can see the game
defensively before it happens and get a
feel for spacing on the attack what
they're going to do before they can
happen by looking at cues I can get into
the right spot so I can put people in
the right places to shut it down before
it happens and kind of
um you know stop the attack and so all
my attention kind of went into that I
was just like I'm going to really Master
this spacing and and seeing it before it
happens kind of mentality and um
yeah kind of changed it to that and that
kind of got me excited to do D and
that's why kind of when I when I gave up
coaching I was kind of like you know
Tech's easy yeah well I think you know I
mean because it's just natural for us
you never go be a tech you could be a
Tech coach you've got to try and come up
with a system but it's you go out there
and back yourself to do natural skills
in it defense you know it's
you don't know what the other two team
team is going to do you can assume you
know what I mean but you don't know and
so you've got to try to always try to
get better and put people in the right
position and get them to see the right
pictures and then also say
you've got to be brave to go out there
and make some tackles too so
um I guess that kind of helped me to
where I am now yeah no doubt that's
interesting it's cool to hear
um that side of it so then you do go to
Toshiba
um over in Japan and what was that
signing like um what's the reason behind
that your body was obviously falling to
pieces because it's just the last last
little Yin run
yeah well like I
um well like I ended up I was going to
sign in Montpellier in the 2013 and end
up signing a four year deal of New
Zealand oh yeah it turned down a lot of
money over there and I was just like ah
I still
want to compete in New Zealand and so
after the Final in 2016 I still had the
17 year in in New Zealand and I was just
like
Toshiba came up and I was like oh yeah
this is the last little bit get a bit of
Yin in the pocket um and go over there
and experience a different culture and a
different rugby you know environment and
um they was you know probably the worst
sign in Toshiba history for them
because I went over there and I went
over there and uh you know I still
wanted to compete but like I said both
knees were gone both Achilles were
screaming and screaming at me I remember
coming home from trainings that
hurricane season and I'll be like saying
it to the Wi-Fi block I can't do this
anymore I'm in so much pain and then you
turn up the training next day and you
put on your act
I'm all good now and you know get
through today and that was my last few
years of playing rugby it was you know
how can I just
put on an act and so I went over there
and
um could hardly run couldn't jump
couldn't so I was kind of like
I was kind of like hoping that I'd go
over there in a little bit of my Rugby
IQ
and help them develop and you know and
that kind of stuff have some input in
that area uh would be beneficial instead
of me having to play all the time
um clearly that didn't work
and
and uh I played 10 games my first year
out of there we're having to play 15 16.
not very well but I you know I played
two of them you were out there no I was
I was out there doing something like not
running really fast or being looking
very agile at all and they're probably
thinking what if we've done here we've
just spent Millions on this guy
oh mate this guy is an absolute Sideshow
he can't even run
um
and yeah and so the next year I actually
again we did hurricanes again for my
last year in 2017. and
um and then I went to Japan Toshiba
again and I actually felt good because I
I think I only played 10 games for the
Hurricanes uh my last year oh yeah and I
paid all of them that you know except
for one so I was broken then but so I
didn't feel too bad when I went to
Toshiba Malaysia and I was 30 34.
and I feel good for the first three
games
and then I pulled my groin and that was
it kind of told me then that you're an
absolute person the body's hell in that
Junior yeah oh so sore like I just
um you know you can only compete and the
mind can tell you so much but it was
like
yeah it's probably time to um
throw them away now yeah you knew you
were done straight away
yeah I knew I was done there yeah so you
know how some people get to the end of
their career and they you know you're
trying to live the dream and hold on a
little bit too long or
um anything like I always you know you
watch NFL shows and all that kind of
stuff and it's like winners time and
you'll know and all that kind of yada
yada and yeah yeah I just I mate I could
I could hardly run and
um
yeah it was just it was no good for
anybody and was it always coaching you
wanted to get into
um post foot it was that always a little
bit of a goal for you
um yeah I think from that 2016 season
where
um obviously John Plum Tree was the B
coach but you know myself TJ Brad
Shields
uh Meri Proctor we were like a defensive
group so we we changed the system after
we got to hide in that first game
against the brumbies
it's all right 50 odd points and they
said we're a phantom I'm pretty sure
there's any bills on the wing that look
fit but the rest of us were
we're throwing them to that sorry I'm
thrown into that um that mix and uh so
we're like you know how we change the
system we were like wow we've got to go
get teams and we kind of
morphed it into something and that kind
of got me excited because every day I'd
be in the coach's office in the morning
and I'd be talking to plums about how we
need to change it and you know trying to
upskill him and me at the same time
because
you know trying to have all these ideas
and that kind of got me
to wanting to build my own system and
and run with it and so when I got to the
end of
my playing days and I managed to get a
chance of the Wellington lions
um I had a system that I wanted
defensively um and I knew what I wanted
to do and start with where
that kind of help I didn't have one on
the tech but I had one on D and that
kind of got me excited
and it definitely worked and it was
something around the because obviously
you're a hot property with the TV as
well you're always good in front of the
camera you did have a few Sky cameos
um people I guess would have assumed you
to be sort of a TV personality post
footy was that ever in the pipeline for
you or where did that stop I remember
when I did my knee and uh
you know I did a little bit of Sky work
um you know pre and post games and all
that kind of stuff to see if I enjoyed
and it was cool it was quite good fun
and I remember
uh when I did the lion so for the first
part of the year when Super Rugby was on
I was able to go and do the sky work or
we'd hit the kickoff show and that kind
of stuff and talk over Super Rugby and
then when the Lions was on obviously I'd
go and comment I'm in coaching mode and
all that kind of stuff so but I I
enjoyed it
um
I guess it was down to who was going to
give me a contract first and I was going
to go with that and clearly clearly the
TV guys didn't think I was good enough
because they didn't give me anything so
um
yeah so coaching was was the next
opportunity and uh but I always thought
um I'd like to do radio you know I
you're a good mate Izzy and all that do
it and yeah um you listen to Beaver in
it just having Yarns and
but I love watching sports so
to talk about sport as a job and then to
have just Yarns
I don't mind um telling stories and
having a good old yarn so uh
you know that kind of stuff would be
cool too but at the moment it's coaching
yeah well snz will be listening to this
and they'll probably be ringing you
straight after this is released because
Matt you'd be you'd be unreal on a radio
uh sports radio show
yeah about to say fire he sounds hoary
on the phone listen to his voice sorry
so what what is your coaching plans like
um have you have you found it have you
found making that transition into
coaching you've spoken about how it sort
of happened but do you love it yeah I do
and I've and I've got better with it
like I
um you know when I first started and
obviously it was different from playing
because you know playing you can you
look after yourself and if you're good
enough you could try and help a few more
people or that kind of stuff where as a
coach
you gotta help everyone you know what I
mean and you've got to be on and
at the beginning I kind of took
everything personal you know like um and
that's only I always been the last year
or maybe the last year where I haven't
taken every line break or missed tackle
or try scored against me personal
um
I was real bad at that I was kind of
like
you know a team scores and it's like
damn it that's my fault you know what I
mean and I should have done better for
um
and so kind of
uh less stress about that you know it's
I've learned to enjoy it a bit more and
um enjoy the moment and enjoy the
coaching and enjoy trying to get guys
better to fulfill their dreams and uh
try and win a championship like you keep
doing
um so
so
um yeah mate but I but I am enjoying it
I am I yeah I love I love going to work
and I love
trying to come up with ideas and
um
you know competing and trying to get the
the men competing as well and
um you know that that's fun to me what's
the hardest thing what's the hardest
thing you've found going from playing to
coaching
uh
uh well the hardest thing is you know I
guess you've got to look after so many
people and and depends I guess what your
your portfolio is you know me as a coach
I try to
I try to give them everything they can
you know I can but it's you know that's
probably not the best thing to do it's
you know you they've got to find their
way a little bit and
um you know it used to stress me out as
like the hardest thing is like I need
you to know this and if I tell you a
thousand different things you'll know
everything on the Rugby field and you'll
be fine and it doesn't work that way
because they would certainly got hey
um so I guess the hardest thing for me
was
you know go oh hang on I can't give you
everything in the world because you're
probably not going to take everything in
the world on so
um it's a massive growth I guess that
part of me because I was always
I like to think that I understood rugby
so I didn't need
you know like I had a little bit of IQ
and you know similar where you can pick
things up as you go by just watching or
in your mind you don't really need to be
told or littered a certain way and my
kind of thing when I came into coaching
it was like
hey if they do this we can do this and
then you can go do this and then you go
you know what I mean it's just like holy
moly and I guess that was
that was the hardest thing for me to
realize is like hey just take it easy
here son
do you miss playing at all no I don't I
don't miss playing because
man I gave it all I could and
um like I said I I remember what my last
two three years were like uh the pain
wise running around and trying to put on
a front that I could still play rugby
and compete and I know what that pain
was like
and so I don't miss it because
yeah I was also in so and I know I know
mate I know I can't play anymore I can't
it's hard for you to say yeah
oh I can see it breaking me right now
also car views up if you give me on it
now but you know what I mean like um
if I don't like if I can go play a game
of rugby if I don't have to Sprint don't
have to stay I don't have to tackle
don't have to clean a rock well you
didn't Toshiba we know
I did it for most of my career man I
don't know what you're talking about
um yeah so
yeah now I I I couldn't do it like I try
and play basketball with my um my
daughter and my nephew and it come up
and
pisses me off because I can't jump
anymore because my you know knees never
gone so the hoop just looks like it's
further Improvement I used to tell I
tell my daughter in it I'm like she goes
can you dunk and I was like man I used
to be able to dunk it easy now I can't
even touch the nip but um I get score by
watching people dunk them up
oh it's depressing I said
yeah
so what's what's the plans um for the
next few years how many years are you
with the canes I just sorting out at uh
that now so
um sorting out a couple more and
I'm trying to yeah did a goal of of what
you fellas did and win the championship
and so hopefully um
hopefully next year it's not you guys
and uh
you give it to somebody else hey what do
you reckon yeah good man
yeah how's um how's clarky fitting in
he's what he's already just come down
this week so
um he's been thrown from one side of the
the facility to the other side just to
try to meet people and
um
yeah so you you'll find us feed over the
next couple of weeks and then
we'll get stuck into it the other two
you've got a couple of coaches who
obviously Whoppers away
otago and Swifty or Tyler oh yeah he's
away or Tonga so
yeah and one more coach to come is that
yeah yeah I think um yeah yeah they're
working on somebody else to come in
there and
uh I don't think that's been solved yet
but
we'll get there
yeah we'll hear this Razer so that'll be
boydy why not surely bought in his
jandals I could imagine
no I think I think Razor's coming in
Manchester
help us help us win the championship
there boy that's all
are you happy with your squad though uh
obviously you've had a pretty young
group for the last few years but
seem to be maturing quite nicely this
year and ready to make that step yeah
most of them uh most of them are back I
think we've got a handful of players or
positions that we need to fill
um like most teams I guess uh so yeah
it's just another year for these guys
the gel as a team and
and hopefully we can all keep getting
better coaches included and um again the
the end goal is to try and win the
championship or at least compete for it
so we finished fifth the last couple
years so we need to do better than that
so it's um
good challenge yeah exciting times for
Hurricane fans which I'm sure there's
plenty out there but anyway they deserve
another championship ah they do at some
point
at some point it's a few more years away
for sure wait come on give myself don't
be like that
anyway we've gone to Instagram for some
questions had thousands and thousands
coming so many of them were about that
Rugby World Cup story of course but we
did get heaps of other ones as well
we'll start with this one how did room
Raiders start and will it ever return as
a coach room Raiders people love room
Raiders
room readers started because I think
pretty did it before me but that I did
it because
um just for fun and I was like I had
mine you know got creative and I was
just like who can I pick that's got a
bit of human I can have a story around
it you know so like oh and I did Victor
he likes drama and reading so I kind of
made him out to be that kind of person
and Izzy and I mean Izzy's just Izzy so
um you know I'm pretty kind of his way
and so I kind of went for guys that you
know didn't mind taking the piss out of
themselves which made it easier to do
and yeah
um it was kind of like just off the cuff
I'd go knock in the room and we'll just
jam and and sort it out and the the next
year when I was in the All Blacks I kind
of got a little bit too scripted and
they were like oh we'll film from this
angle and then we'll go and redo it
again
it's just it's off the cuff kind of
thing so kind of that's how it died yeah
oh niggly would you do it as a coach
bring it back
I'm going to the coach's rooms maybe
some horrible Rigs and uh
hey guys
stay out of lady's room Fair ladies very
much so maybe I could do it for every
franchise and I'll go down now we're
starting with the Highlanders and
Tom Dudley everyone
and just work my way around
yeah oh mate it's got potential Sky TV
might come crawling back if you start
releasing those let's go
let's go okay next one this one came in
quite um often as well it's around the
fin what's the key to a good fend
um location like I
um I just kind of I backed myself to
be strong in that area but location if
you take what they're giving you if it's
a shoulder if it's a chest if they try
and whack it down put them in the do it
in the face so
um and again I only got good at it
because
I couldn't bump anyone over so I had to
try to stay away from the bigger guys so
um make it look like a punch and throw
it as hard as you can
how did you practice it like it's it is
quite a tough skill to practice is it
yeah I'd win the old man when I'd come
home after the lights were on the street
lights and he'd be chasing me under the
fend them off and
no it was um I don't know how I I just
started just like kind of it was there
and then
um
yeah just kind of
I don't even know if I trained it that
hard it was you know you throw a couple
pads and thin there but it was just more
in game I kind of got a lot of
opportunities to do it yeah because
obviously it's hard when you're playing
by yourself playing on both sides of the
ball hard to get that thing really going
no well just just running around going
like this all day now I didn't I didn't
really hear it
from nobody as well back in the days do
me
in
okay
oh this is a good one tell us this I
hope it's a good one it looks like a
good one tell us the story of when you
blocked Jamie Joe's mum's toilet and
Christmas so and Felipe we're going to
beat up cozy because you didn't own it
I'm saying was that Tom's right there
wasn't
because
when we're down there on uh from on our
camp and someone someone went toilet and
you know you never own up and clean it
up no one's going to clean up a toilet
unless you did it and floss was like
Amy's up to sitting at the top and he's
like just someone clean it and all times
was down with me and mercy was walking
around trying to get everyone and floss
was like don't worry boys I'll clean it
up and he's got like the broom and the
mop clean up the bathroom we were like
buddy it was him
tell you another story though and now
that Tom's is on there and want to start
their trouble
he was like he woke me up in the middle
in the morning he was like yes come on
son let's go and I was like we were
going to just go for a run so it ran
down the road same place ran down the
road and then he was like stop after
about 500 meters and he was like dead or
dude and I was like what and then he was
like put here toilet paper
and we jumped in the bush because he
knew that the toilet wasn't working
there you go Toms
so the toilet was ruined
I thought it was ruined toilet got
flooded
because it was Ross it was somebody
um oh so it wasn't actually yeah it's
confirmed no no it wasn't me no and then
in the dark in the morning times was
like come for a run
but he only wanted me to go for a run so
he'd go for two in the tree why did he
want you to go with him because he was
back he didn't want to go by himself so
he made up we're going for a run so he
ran down the street about 500 meters and
he was like oh dear and he jumped in the
bushel of his toilet paper
hahaha
oh geez that is nice
oh because staff okay this one this is
probably one of my all-time favorite
pranks talk us through the hanzai noodle
prank hmm
that year I done my knee and um
and so I was out and cool kids wanted to
do like a punked the essence kind of
thing and so I was gonna effectively
gonna be him but they wanted to do like
Dan Carter and Richie and all that and I
was just like well you're not going to
get away with them because the
collective three guys had to be in the
same you couldn't do one-on-one and I
was like they've been around too long
they'll know that so you've got to get
the young guys and so
um cozy and about Bowden and Francis
Haley were like get those guys in
mate it was it was funny because
everyone want to sit you know like
the speak English it was a Japanese set
one of the guys was Korean he didn't
even know what the Japanese guys were
saying it was brilliant and we were just
suddenly going I'd tell the guy what to
say and I'll go make it look like this
and yada yada and mate they believed
that it was quite it was one of the best
ones the hanzai noodle still gets thrown
around at hurricanes base now to Golden
so you can't beat it when he's doing the
run away from the shark the gift that
keeps on giving it one
hahaha oh so good the net it was from
around that moment where I thought that
you're definitely going to go into TV
and little shows like that um
those pranks would be absolute gold
wouldn't it yeah yeah well
clearly didn't happen oh
right there's still hope this is
the next one how much stick did he get
for the Falcon against the tars in 08
yeah I am knocked me out so I don't
remember it
um well I remembered it now because I've
seen it so all I remember was it was a
minute something into the game and
currently build called a Mark or
something he was going to kick the ball
now so I'm going to charge this down and
then I took off and then I stopped I was
like I'm not going to get there and
that's all I remembered and then I got
up
and I apparently I I wouldn't go the
wrong way so I ran back to backfield and
I remember asking Alby matthewson I was
like man what happened I thought I got
like a shoulder or knee and he's like
the ball hit you in the face and I was
like shut up so I turned around the
Rodney and I go what happened he was
like the ball hit you in the face and I
was like what
and then um it wasn't until I kind of
like so embarrassing it wasn't until I
came to with about 20 minutes to go in
the game
and then after the game I watched the
footage and I was like oh it's so
embarrassing I hurt my knee because I
got folded but I didn't feel that until
20 minutes to go
um and then the review on Monday Colin
Cooper was like we had a move where line
out crashed in the middle and I was at
fullback supposed to switch back down
the Blind and I was standing out the
other side of it here yeah and he was
out on the far side now like Corey where
were you were supposed to switch and I
was like don't remember it being called
so
it wasn't um
wasn't my finest memory true so that
you'd be completely offering hia from
that now these days I mean now you'd be
gone gone be gone now yeah fully knocked
out from the Falcon
and uh yeah and I heard my MCL because I
got folded like a like a dick chair and
just went down on my knee and
uh shambles good times good lessons Okay
next one does he still have a bath with
a fizzy and lollies
um I have a bath I'm waiting for you to
hang up so I can go and have one I don't
I don't drink fizzy and I have lollies a
little bit I don't drink fuzzy anymore I
um sparkling water of um
I've stopped taking Fizzies I have like
a half a glass every now and then I was
waiting for Pepsi Max to sponsor me and
they never did so I quit
um and so now I just drink um like
sparkling water or water yeah when did
this when how long have you been fizzy
free for
right it'll be about five months oh five
months I stopped um stopped drinking it
so
how are you feeling and when I mean
fizzy I don't mean alcohol because I
still drinking but just fuzzy yeah like
Coke you used to have like
was it what a bottle at least two liters
in a day was it someone's rumored to say
yeah
easy easy I'd sit in there I'll sit in
the bathroom not down to 1.5 like it was
like it was nothing but I wouldn't have
sugar ones you know it's always diet
yeah
well did that means anything different
um
yeah so yeah for about yes I kind of
stopped doing that and
kind of feel beautiful oh good on you
okay three more because I know you want
to get back in the bath best coach you
played under
uh coach I liked I liked uh Jason
Holland who's
gone to the All Blacks now and I liked
uh Ian Foster I thought for
uh as a as a Tech coach
um obviously I never played on the
Lima's as head coaches but as a tech
coaches I thought their level of detail
and
um you know being able to give you the
right pictures to go out there and play
was was awesome so
um
yeah the two people that stick out as as
fuzzy and we call them iffy because if
me and nazini hated that so
um yeah that'd be the best ones that
stick out to me Effie and Alfie and
Alfie yep
foreign
how did you become such a sex symbol
that's right
um
just by telling everyone I was one
that's pretty much it
easy is that
okay last question best piece of advice
you have for a woodland listener this
piece of advice
um yeah go on
no I I don't know like I the thing I I
say now to um
there's an ongoing thing to my daughter
because she's our sporty one in the
family and the rest of them
don't care about it oh my thing and who
now was we talk about other people
every time she's playing basketball
netball I said other people try
I see we compete so I said so whatever
you do whether you're the best or not
just go and compete you know don't you
just don't go and try compete and so
um
she kind of
gets that and enjoys it and it kind of
makes me feel like
I'm helping out even though
probably not but so probably that one
just
yeah yeah
yeah big big fan of that I'm going to
use that on my kids as well I like the
wording don't try we compete yeah that's
got me up yeah nice
anyway I'll let you go to have your bath
but um really appreciate you coming on
the podcast
um true legend true lad um awesome
Journey
um what a career and awesome to see you
doing your doing a bit for the
Hurricanes as the defensive coach one of
the greats one of the best D coaches in
the country so
um looking forward to catching up
whenever we play and
um yeah thanks for coming on the podcast
mate okay mate take care do I get paid
for this or yep um Fizzies how many
Fizzies do you want
no I don't drink fuzzies anymore man so
so I guess it's free is it space Fizzies
fuzzies
send us up on a couple of crates there
boy